thank you very much we are living in an
amazing time of feisty comedy TV drama
which specifically shows how fabulous
women are when they're flawed we're in
the era of big little lives of Lena
Dunham girls of Phoebe water bridges
flea bag and the point is you can't be
what you can't see and we need to see
ourselves reflected in the culture that
we consume to know that we're not alone
as a messy chaotic mother who drinks
smokes and swears much too much I've
really never seen my world represented
on TV before the show's made by
glamorous comedy actress of the year the
very brilliant
Sharon Hogan sews catastrophe and her
American shoulder boards are
groundbreaking shameless liberating
brave feminists and cripplingly honest
in real life she is just as beautiful
she's just as flawed she's just as funny
and the second bottle of tequila that
she was just finishing when my kids came
down to breakfast the morning after my
birthday party this year had just this
catastrophic results as you were the
Pope glamorous people I give you the
brilliant fuck-ups that is Sharon Morgan
Emma you [ __ ] I did that for you in
your birthday and thank you very much oh
my god there is so many women in this
room that I am in awe of and it's giving
me really bad anxiety actually I feel
like a bit sick like no I'm not gonna
hurl but I need to use the toilet and
it's a bit more than usual and I would
like to thank glamour and Jo Alvin for
giving me this award and also for giving
me an outfit this morning it's really
long it covers everything I didn't have
to shave I did have to fluff I didn't
have to promise anything no I did I did
all that anyway
just from my own you know self-worth I
would like to thank it's for apache' so
I want to thank channel 4 and J Hunt and
all the channel 4 at Bob's and Amazon
and Joe Lewis very getting behind us and
I really want to thank Rob Delaney
because Proctor lady he was the one who
got his script he was when he got a
sitcom commissioned and for whatever
reason he decided that he did know how
to write a sitcom and so he asked me to
help him and if it wasn't for him I'd
still be knocking on doors trying to get
pilots picked up and there would
probably be a very funny very successful
show but a man who really enjoys his
food and so and thank you very much
and here's to the City of London and the
City of Manchester and and for the right
result on Thursday not resume
[Applause]